hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're back on Monster Hunter
we're gonna be doing my solo guide again
and we're gonna be tackling there ghonte
aka spiky boy and we're gonna see how to
defeat him solo so let's get right into
it
there gurgaon say according to the lore
is an elder dragon who feasts on other
elder dragons this is definitely one of
the harder boss fights in the game so
far it took me about four attempts and
11 deaths but I finally managed to slay
him and solo and with that time I
quickly learned all the moves the helix
to use one tip is that you have to be
very careful with noggin ghonte because
he's very fast and an aggressive monster
and rarely seems to ever run out of
stamina so let's start off how we did
the last time and go over the psychology
report so according to the psychology
part which you get from reaching
research level 1 it says his legs head
and horns are his weak points his horns
and tail are the only breakable
inseparable parts of his body now based
off the weapon you use you could do
certain damage to a certain spot to
maximize your damage output blunt
weapons such as hammers and the like
should focus on heads and horns the
sharp weapon should focus on the horns
and the legs and for the fate and the
face for the ranged weapons on the right
side it shows his weaknesses and his
ailments and for weaknesses he's mostly
weak to thunder and dragon and the same
across the board for all ailments so
choose what you like I definitely do
recommend to use thunder and Dragon
though next up is the loadout I
currently have the entire Oro Dagon set
I apologize I'm pretty sure I butchered
that name I'm very bad at pronouncing
names in this game but it is the monster
in the rotten veil that does bleed
damage to you I have his entire set
except the arms and the helmet my helmet
is the bone armor in the high-ranked
tier and my arms are the arms of Zora
Magda Rose I highly recommend Armour in
the high tier especially because of how
much damage he does and because that
will give you a ton of defence my weapon
of choice was the dual blades of blast
damage but going back to the report
thunder and Dragon will be your best
option
I was still gathering the research
points while I was fighting him so I had
no clue that those were his weaknesses
but once again now you know
as for the pelacone I didn't really
focus on him too much I mostly used him
as bait when I needed to heal or equip a
mantle so that is entirely your choice
although if you are going to use yours
but I recommend what I did and use the
vigor wasp I use the Vigoroth so that I
can have an extra set of healing items
just in case I ran out of max potions
for the loadout make sure to have mega
nutrients to maximize or hell
mega potions - and keep them tons of
them stored in your chest you're going
to be using a lot of these for when you
need to heal and even some max potions
which will here your entire health bar
all the way up to full just in case if
you need some help a cool drink is
another very good choice as well but
I'll explain why in a little bit I also
grab some barrel bombs for the last
phase but they aren't entirely necessary
if you're low on xeni I recommend not
using these and probably saving them to
buy some potions and such but if you
have the cash for which you probably
should and definitely go grab some of
these the vitality mantle is almost a
must for this flight because you're
gonna be getting hit a lot in the
vitality mantle again takes a certain
amount of threshold of damage and just
completely negates it but it goes into
the armor making the armor weaker until
it fully disappears and then lastly is
to make sure you eat I even went mid
fight during it I was fighting him it
said that I could heal again so I went
back mid flight ran all the way back up
to spawn to eat food and then - and then
fought him again I chose the food that
gave the attack in defense buffs but
once again that's completely up for
debate and it's entirely on you also if
there's any tips that you have that I
may have missed put it in the comments
for other players to see if they're
still stuck on this fight and now that
we're all set let's get into the fight
so to start remember naraka ghonte is an
elder dragon meaning he can't be caught
by traps and the like so don't bother
spending money on them one huge tip is
that on his wings head back and arms are
spikes hence the name spiky boy these
recharge after some time if not
destroyed they will eventually turn
black
once they're all once they all turn
black be aware because this is where his
most powerful moves will come out he
will basically roar fly into the air and
dive bomb causing all his spikes to
break off and hit you if you're nearby
this can be avoided by sprint jumping
and which I said in the last video with
Diablos has incredible invincibility
frames causing you to take no damage
just like in this clip here another one
is a very slow but devastatingly
powerful Grom palm with his claw this
can also be avoided by sprint jumping
but the best course of action is to
dodge by his tail and completely miss
the hit so that you believe that you
will leave him open for a bit and give
you some free hits this move also has a
different variation to it if the move is
shorter he will just immediately slam
his hand on the ground and fling spikes
at you but if it's longer it'll just be
a ground pound and that's it another
three moves he likes to use are what I
call winged slide wings
and tail smash wings slide is where he
goes on his side and slides across the
floor and hit you with his back he we
used this move when close by so you have
a quick time to react to him on this one
knowing when it's coming is key because
if you react you can dodge the wings by
rolling into the tail and you can also
get some free hits while he tries to get
up for the winged fling move he flings
his wings out to his sides and if next
to him they will hit you you can tell
when this movies about to happen because
the wings will be at his side's like
this fight in the clip I'm showing now
and then lastly is the tail smash this
will only happen when you're behind him
he will smash his tail on you to prevent
you from hitting him in the tail because
once again that is also a weak point so
be careful when attacking his tail now
that the main moves are done let's move
to the areas and see what we can do with
that the rotation of where he spawns is
different every time
so we'll go from where I went most of
these areas sadly don't have much to
help you like para toads like in the
Diablos fight and flash flies and such
like that but in the first area it is
the I like to call the Crystal Room with
towers surrounding it definitely use
these towers as cover if you want to
heal or to protect yourself from an
attack they are very useful the next
area is technically the beginning it is
a wide open area sadly there is nothing
really here to help you
you can potentially mount in here on the
small elevated rocks towards the back or
if you climb up on the vines if you're
really risky but that's basically it for
this area the third area is another
Crystal Room except with a little bit
more cover same as usual nothing really
to help you here but there are crystal
bursts you can use as slinger ammo to
stop in Ergon say for a bit if he's in
the middle of a move but they only do 14
damage so they're basically used just to
stop him if you're kind of in the middle
and you're probably stuck on something
like if you're trying to heal and you
dodged away hit him with the slinger and
it'll give you enough time to regenerate
your health for a bit the fourth area is
on the top right next to the camp before
you drop down into the official arena at
the start this is a better position for
mounting and the ramp on the side can
provide decent cover as well there's
also some little plants that I believe
give you antidote but since he doesn't
really do poison these are kind of
useless the second last area is what I
like to call the fire pit going back to
what we said about having the cool drink
the cool drink will protect you from the
fire damage because if you walk on it
you will take some fire damage use this
to prevent all of it this is more of a
hazard say to you as it is to him
so I always try to have a cool drink on
hand for this fight because without the
cool drink you can only go on the rocky
parts not affected by the lava without
getting hit and that makes the arena
really small but if you have a cool
drink you could be walking on the lava
as much as you want making the area a
little bit bigger and more area for you
to move around and for the final area it
is newark agon taze Nest he will likely
reach eat after limping which is they
signed the he is weak I like to use this
time to load up on the barrel bombs and
blow them up near his spikes if there
are any that are white to do some damage
usually at the beginning once he wakes
up he will try to dive-bomb the wall and
open up the Madelon map a little bit
this will also give you another mounting
position once again it's similar to the
one in the main area not very big in
terms of a jump but it is the
possibility of being there
there are also icicles hanging from the
ceiling that can hurt you if Naga ganze
either hits the wall or the ground too
hard I'm not entirely sure on that but
they don't really do lots of damage to
you or Naga ghonte I believe they do
like very minor chip damage to you and
do about one damage to him the icicles
though will knock you back if you're hit
by them which of your position wrong
could lead you into some very bad
trouble so definitely be aware of where
they're falling and then congrats you
have beaten nurger ghonte once again if
there's any questions you have comment
them down below and I will try to answer
them as best I can as well if there's
any tips you have that I have missed
also leave them down there as well once
you've finished beating your gurgaon say
there's going to be a quest where you
have to track down a few other ancient
elder dragons don't worry about that I
also have a guide coming either Thursday
or Friday because this video should be
up on Wednesday of that of how to get
those tracks so don't worry about that
there should be it by the time you beat
this about 4 to 5 Dru enemies left so
definitely expect guides on those
characters as well in the near future
thank you guys for watching the video if
you did enjoy please sure to give it a
like if you're new around here then
subscribe I'm covering a lot of Monster
Hunter content a lot of the guy it's a
lot of the news when they come out
mostly guides on the characters and
other little tidbits of information that
are very helpful a lot of you guys seem
to be watching my mounting video I'm
super happy about that it was the first
ever monster on her video and I got 30
it's at 33,000 views at the moment so I
really do appreciate the immense amount
of support on that one and the Diablo
solo guide so thank you guys for that
once again subscribe if you're new I
cover all that stuff I previous
mentioned my two most recent videos are
going to be popping up on the screen and
Monster Hunters and definitely check
those out if you haven't already and
with that guys up we have a great rest
of your day and peace out